the Joe Rogan experience well you don't
live in freakin no but la but eventually
I'm gonna move out of California how
dare you yeah
I'm the older no not that much time I
think pretty soon no yeah you mean get a
place but you're still gonna be here I'm
gonna be storing [ __ ] I'm gonna
eventually move yeah what yeah for good
yeah keep a place here and I'm probably
gonna still do shows out of the studio
I'll fly in to do them like I'll
probably wind up banking them like doing
them in a week and then taking the rest
of the month off Wow
yeah I don't want to be what about the
store there's two minutes well I love
the store but you know I also love the
improv but doing a lot of improv shows
the props great sounds great yeah ice
house is amazing I'm still gonna do
shows but I really think that there's
something that's taxing about the volume
of people here agree that bothers
especially with kids when again when I
came back from Italy you know I was in
Italy for 12 days when I came back like
the [ __ ] highway and we landed at
like 10 o'clock at night just
bumper-to-bumper on the 405 I was like
this is stupid
this is a stupid place to live because I
travel so much I know I mean I could
travel out of Denver you know I could
live in Denver and travel out of there
I'm just crowded [ __ ] do this bad month
move in there it's a beast it's blowing
up it's a lot yeah maybe Montana places
to live that are more peaceful yeah but
are you gonna be satisfied not doing
sets every night at the store man oh
there's no way mm-hmm like your
happiness you know I'm saying like it's
a weird balance because I hear you I
hear you where the bounce for your
family and stuff but like I check off
boxes when I go out at night and I can I
see it like my I I don't I don't you're
saying I don't hang out man
I hang out to store when I see you there
at the improv when I see my friends or
this is me hanging out I check those
boxes on that I don't hang out man yeah
I need that
yeah for my own sanity it's good but I
mean I feel like you can also get that
when you tour you know you can get that
when you go in the weekends I think I'd
have to do more clubs I can't just do
theaters because I really feel like it's
a numbers thing like in terms of
most like if you're doing cardio well
you can't do hard cardio once a week
inspect expect to be in shape you won't
be in shape do a bunch just do it many
many times a week so if you're going to
live somewhere other than LA I feel like
you have to do at least five sets a week
I think that's the magic number so I
think you'd have to do a weekend where
you're doing two shows a night Friday
two shows a night Saturday and you'd
have to do a week night Thursday Friday
so yeah Thursday Friday Saturday or
Friday Saturday Sunday we can open your
club Saturday is better than Thursday
and Friday Saturday Sunday Sunday can
suck my dick yeah Sunday my fun that's
the Lord's Day bro more of a night
everybody's exhausted cut don't do
Sunday enjoy Diaz I think you enjoy Diaz
Tony never do Sunday's I did it once and
I was depressed but also then I don't
get a day off with my family yeah not
good don't work Monday nights and then I
don't work Sundays it's the only rule
those are smart days yeah yeah I'm the
same way with you Sunday and Monday is
how I've been doing it lately yeah and
you got to do that you gotta have those
boundaries where you decide to take
nights I mean occasionally I'll do a
Monday night but most of times not most
the time I take those off but I think
there's a real benefit to not being
overrun by the volume of people out here
is that what you think that's why Dave
one of the reasons he excels you guys
are similar with that where you don't
you're not really tuned in with like the
masses
meet me in tune in where you're not
glued to your freaking no winners well
so he's not in to go on the like red
carpet events and getting photomeatery
let's do you hate that [ __ ] well I just
feel like it's a circle jerk you know
and everybody's just you know it's just
weird the whole celebrity world is very
weird it's very weird but I get how
people love when you're famous and then
you're around other famous people
there's the only people that think
you're normal you know they also
understand what you're going through
yeah yeah